[Music]
okay so everybody hear me right
I'm Matt I work on moment jazz everybody
in the room use mama jazz to people yes
lots of people pretty much everybody
we've been lucky enough to become one of
the the premier big time libraries for
JavaScript we didn't set out to do that
it would have been nice if it's
JavaScript date was good from the
beginning so that's kind of what I want
to talk to you about today how did we
get here what can you do today
are there other good options other than
moments yes I think there are and what
are we going to do in the future so I
work at Microsoft I'm a site reliability
engineer which means I don't do a lot of
JavaScript in my day time I have been a
JavaScript programmer for quite a while
though and I am a net developer I mainly
focus on the domain of date and time so
if you ever have questions about
date/time timezone daylight saving time
how to schedule things any of those
sorts of topics you can probably find me
on Stack Overflow that's usually where I
hang out I also have a lot of open
source date/time related libraries and
if you've got big time bugs in your open
source project I may have lurked on you
and jumped in and fixed it and you may
like but that's what I do and I like
cheese because everybody likes cheese so
what is a date let's talk about these I
think a date looks like this January 1st
everybody agree with me that's a date
yeah I think that's the date but you
know that's gets us end of problems with
JavaScript you know if we take a look at
this little demo that I made here this
is literally all I have I have a
html5 date input type okay and all I'm
going to do with that is just give you
the output I'm going to feed the output
of that value into a date object and
just because I'm only looking at the
date I'm going to say to date string and
what happens let's just say I was born
today okay what happened here
I picked May 7th but I got me six
somebody ever run into this problem with
the data object this is one of the
things that people yell and scream about
the data object what's going on here
what's going on here is that I'm from
the United States and I have an adjusted
money this can this computers time zone
to be east as the UTC line it's still
west of it so if you happen to be that
negative offsets from UTC you'll find
that JavaScript will throw your dates
off by one and this happens because the
Equusearch specification originally
wasn't clear about what to do when you
only have a date
it just said if I've got some value and
I don't know the offset then the offset
must be UTC well what's a UTC day from
UTC midnight to UTC the end of midnight
the only people that I know of that are
always on a UTC day are mostly in
Iceland Iceland is on GMT year-round
even in Greenwich where they draw the
Greenwich main line that's not a new TC
all the time their UTC plus one right
now for British summer time so there's a
discrepancy in the last two forms here
between the ISO 8601 specification which
is where we get all of our date and time
standards from and the atmosphere
specification and as you can see the
third item on there is a date a time and
originally the the atmosphere
specification so that should be TC but
they later corrected it to be local so
fortunately for date and time forms we
now know that we are all modern
evergreen browsers will be on local time
but for date forms it got stuck with UTC
and and really this comes down to web
allottee we wanted to change it the
implementers all wanted to change it but
when chrome tried there was so much lash
back and so many bugs raised within a
small 24 hour window that they just had
to revert and so the Ekman script spec
now says for date only forms their UTC
and that's just because that's the
reality of the web that we've all had
since the early days of the internet but
a date like what is a date it's not just
what we pointed out earlier well it
should be but in JavaScript it's not
in JavaScript it's not really a date
it's a timestamp it's the number of
seconds sense of the number of
milliseconds since the UNIX epoch which
is in terms of UTC so you can't have
what we lose we lost the display here
come on there we go so we can't have
just a date represented in terms of
milliseconds you all should probably
know this but not every day is a whole
number of 24 hours exactly and the days
that aren't are random all around the
world because of time zones when we're
in standard time and then we switch to
summer time or we call it daylight time
in parts of the world our day shrinks or
gets longer so we'll have a 23 hour
local day or a 25 hour local day
depending on which way we're
transitioning that's during the spring
forward fall back thing and if you live
in this little island off the coast of
Australia called Lord Howe Island it's a
wonderful vacation spot they only switch
by half an hour so you'll have 23 and a
half hour day or 24 and a half hour day
so you can't just measure a date in
terms of milliseconds it's the wrong
type I like to call it a date ish you
know we have a falsie truthy it's not a
date it's a date ish there's this
wonderful quote off by one and naming
things cache of validation doesn't
really apply here I usually throw time
zones into the mix of things that are
hard in computer science so one wonders
like you know what were they thinking
why did we do this
and I have to go back to the beginning
and Brendan Eich one of the inventors of
JavaScript called live script back then
it's been very clear on this point
they had very little time to do this and
they were just told make it look like
Java and you know he's told us many
times and there's a couple blog posts
actually wasn't Brendan implemented it
with Ken Smith of Netscape took the
java.util date code from Java and C in
the implementation and translated it
into the implementation for the early
days of JavaScript this is what that
looked like everybody thinks that like
all happened all at once but if you look
at the date we can see that like when
they develop that Java was in beta
nobody had used this thing they just
said well it's Java going to JavaScript
and this is how Java does date so that's
how Java scripts going to do date and by
the time Java 100 came out the
JavaScript prototype was kind of set in
stone and then when Java 1 1 came out we
deprecated almost all of the
functionality from the data object they
moved it off to Java something called
Java util calendar
so what we're stuck with in in
JavaScript is a model that was
fundamentally broken and found pretty
early on and we never did anything about
we published echo script 100 after the
date deprecation and ever went back and
adjust to that and that's just what we
have today so there's a lot of things
that are wrong besides just the day
parsing I showed you how when you parse
a date you can be off by one but look at
this code can can anybody guess what
this result is this looks reasonable a
lot of people would write something like
this so think in your mind what you
might think it is I look at that and I
say well it's December 31st I'm adding a
month so it must be January 31st as a
result December yeah March yeah so we're
end up in March and we end up at March
2nd but only when I run this code from
from this time zone here in Berlin
because notice the original date values
I gave it were in terms of local time
and it also did something implicit in
this too I so string which will also do
the TTC or to you TTC string or to GMT
string functions it converted it from
local time TTC time and a gave me a UTC
based timestamp so not only do I end up
on March 2nd because I've actually
started on November 31st which doesn't
exist
so I started actually I'm starting on
January 31st so I went to February 31st
which doesn't exist so I went into March
and then I went back an hour for UTC so
there's a lot of things wrong with this
the other thing that it highlights is
that data is mutable notice how I added
a month I had to get the month and then
increment it and they rely on this
bubbling functionality in order to move
from one month to the next these are
really difficult concepts especially for
a beginner developer date and almost any
other language is a value type it's
immutable
it doesn't change once you create it if
you add a month you have a specific
method add a month then you get back the
one with the month added and the other
thing that we have wrong with date is
notice nowhere in here did I say what
time zone I was starting in I just
started in local time so the only thing
the data object supports is the local
time of environment it's running on and
UTC well that's really bad if you're a
node developer because nobody cares
about the time zone on your server
you really shouldn't care about the time
zone on your server anyway all right
let's just do one more here I love this
one
strings and numbers should be
interchangeable and most Java Script
things we have string 0 a regular 0 0 0
or 0 0 0 does anybody think we should
all give the same results whatever it
might be they kind of feel like they
should be defaults I'll give you a hint
there in order they're in there in
descending order here every one of those
things is going to give you something
different and that's sort of the first
ones because when you only pass the
number as a string it's treated as a
year so year 2000 and anything that is
passed as the number is treated as a
timestamp so we're right at the epoch
there notice it's not
launched midnight on the one with deep
pockets it's one o'clock in the morning
so it's not even the same time I'm going
to same timezone for all of those
because this timezone is plus one in
January 1900 is because if you pass a
year from 0 to 99 JavaScript data object
treats that as 1900 to avoid y2k
problems but as soon as you go to year
100 that is year 100 so they're not even
sequential in order of the input
parameters in 1899 just because well the
overflow situation I showed you before
we have no such thing as the 0s day of a
month so it goes back to the one day so
what do we do about this well we saw
what with libraries that's what Java did
Java came out with joda-time if your
Java developer you should be familiar
with Jota time Jota time is now or was
the basis for this thing called jsr 3:10
which made its way into Java 8 and if so
if you're using modern Java you should
be on Java 8 using the Java time package
that is basically joda-time reincarnate
with a few tweaks to make it better
there is an alternate one that is we're
also very good called time for J and
they take a little bit different
philosophy between the two on the
JavaScript side we also had to address
this with libraries really early on
there was a date Jay s library I don't
recommend use that today just because
it's in a poor state of maintainability
but sugar and moment came on the scene
around 2011 and sugar is still pretty
good if you want to do something called
natural language parsing like if you
have a string that says like what time
is it three days and two months from now
and it's actually spelled out as a
string sugar will parse that for you and
try to make a good guess about it so
it's still a good library but most
people are using moment moment does
about 90% of the things you'd want to do
with with date and time maybe even 99%
but you know moment isn't the only thing
out there there are people working on a
port of the joda-time standard into
JavaScript that's as JH Oda library I
think Jay showed is pretty awesome
there's also this thing called date
functions which has gotten a lot of
notoriety lately D functions says
instead of a very large JavaScript
object is all you need to do is add a
month let's just add a month so it's
just like you pull in individual
functions for doing individual things so
I'm going to show you those three
libraries because that's what everybody
uses moment is probably something I saw
the raise of hands everybody's familiar
with we're very specific with moment
when we do our parsing we don't make
that assumption that the JavaScript data
object habit said I can tell what you
want by the string you happen no I can't
always tell what you want sometimes you
have to tell me so if you give me a
string with no context and you don't
tell me what it is then I'll assume it's
local time because that's what the data
object does if you give me a string with
no context and you tell me you wanted
UTC then I'll assume it's UTC and we
have timezone support through the moment
timezone library that imports the INF
standard times on database it pretty
much all modern computing uses moments
API is fluent and intentional so we can
do something like add 200 days and then
we can format that I can tell you
exactly what my input file should be so
there's no confusion on whether that's
July 5th or May 7th because I'm telling
you explicitly but it's day month year
format the only problem that we have
lately with moment is it is still a
mutable API and that's because what was
originally developed it was built using
the JavaScript date object as its basis
so notice I cloned the moment here
before I start adding to it if I didn't
do that it wouldn't just output the same
string here but it would also change the
value of this M variable so it's
important when you're working with
moment that you realize it does mutate
the object as you work through its API
that's something we're considering for a
moment three oh there's some work in
progress on that so hopefully we'll have
a moment three Oh with an immutable API
and yes you can do things like from now
and get seven months you can validate
simple dates it does what it says it
does and it does it pretty good let's
look at this date functions library I
mentioned date functions like I said
it's very light
modular the intent was eight functions
is every single function is its own
module so you only pull in the ones you
need if all I need is something that
will format a string and add some days
then I just import those two functions
and it uses data objects as I was saying
so I created a table ject I format it I
get the output again remember the
JavaScript data object has zero base
month so it looks like I'm passing jr.
first I'm not I'm passing in February
first so when I format that as a string
I see it as February first and again
with the the add date function here it
does what it says it does it adds days
and it is immutable so it didn't change
the value of D 1 as added days to create
day 2 so if you want lately immutable
functions check out date functions JC
Jota being the the other library that I
mentioned is also really good it also
has an immutable API it models
separation of concerns very well so we
have a different objects which is a
local date and local in this context
doesn't mean local to the computer it
means not local Ami's could be local
anywhere it means somebody's local and
that's just terminology that's been
borrowed over from the ISO 8601 standard
into joda-time into Java and now up into
J's Jota so you may see that a few
places when we work with this API we
don't we don't have to have the API
guess what we want we tell it
specifically we want we say here's a
date get the start of the day I want
that for Berlin and then I want to know
what the equivalent time is in the
computer's local time or in UTC I can do
these things very easily the start of
day function is really interesting
concept also keep in mind that because
of those daylight saving time
transitions not every day starts right
at midnight so a start of day isn't just
snaps at midnight and truncate off data
if you're in Brazil or if you other
place around the world when they start
daylight saving time they go right from
11:59 59 of the night before up to 0 1 0
0 so you have to have those rules in
your data to know
start a day is not necessarily midnight
and joda-time is also non mutating its
immutable so we have d1 and d2 here
being different objects the same as I
showed you before so what are we going
to do you know how are we going to get
out of this mess where we don't have to
use libraries or deal with an API that's
broken I think we should fix it
fielding which is fix it let's fix it so
working on that is Maggie sitting right
up here she's on the tc39 committee and
representing the JavaScript foundation
moment jess is a JavaScript foundation
number along with a lot of other really
great libraries Brian Charlson at
Microsoft is also helping with this and
we reach stage one which basically means
we have the general approval of the
committee to think about how we want to
do a new data API we have a general kind
of idea about what we want but it is not
locked in so definitely come take a look
and give your opinions where we'll take
issues on github we'll take pull
requests we'll take any way you want to
talk to us or just come find Maggie and
talk to her after the talk here
generally we want to make date better we
want to learn from the api's that have
come before us not just in JavaScript
but in other languages we want to be
comfortable for everybody uses
JavaScript so it needs to be automatic
it needs to not bring in a whole lot of
Java cruft and other things that don't
apply in JavaScript at least not today
and and yes we're going to do the one
base model we're not going to do 0 based
one so I will put my foot down on that
possible ideas sure it might look like
moment it might look like joda-time
it might look like time for j it might
be that we just provide some missing
functionality in the underlying platform
so that date libraries can do what they
need to do in a smaller and more direct
way but we don't know yet so help us
figure it out here are some examples and
you can see we have this zone date/time
object that's a very Jodha like object
but I'm not doing a lot of object
construction to get the time zone I'm
just passing them along as strings if I
want to add time I might do some like
add too
and then put ours and string and that's
very moment like so we can we can do
some of those kinds of things what else
might we be able to do this is actually
a very complex problem if you're in a
scheduling environment if I say I need
to run an event at the same time every
day but it's in the users local day so
this is you know a starting point and I
say I want the next four occurrences but
I'm crossing a daylight saving time
transition so 8 a.m. every day even when
the offset and the Pacific time zone
changes from minus 8 to minus 7 and you
can see here the the UTC output has
changed also so I cannot schedule an UTC
time I need to schedule in local time
and doing that without a library is
really really hard with the JavaScript
data object most people would just say
plus 24 times 60 times 60 times whatever
to get the next instant but then you'll
find you're running at 7 a.m. or 9 a.m.
they'll be off by one moment and their
libraries can help but we want to do
this built-in it would look something
like this so if you think this looks
awful and you have a better idea come
talk to us if you think this is great
let us know and that's really all I got
so please give your feedback if you have
other questions come find me afterwards
or you can always post on Stack Overflow
if you just tag it with date time or
timezone I'll find it probably lots of
other people do as well and I have a six
hour long course on date and time
fundamentals on Pluralsight if you
really want to dive in so thank you very
much
[Applause]
thank you